à plaisir les masques des agents de la
ville sont maintenant recycler c'est
grâce à recques n'aurait qu'une société
basée dans la commune et qui produit des
matériaux éco responsable à partir de
déchets qui échappe aux filières de
recyclage après les avoir laissé deux
semaines à température ambiante pour des
contaminations
ils sont broyés pour obtenir des
paillettes des paillettes comme ça que
vous voyez où ailleurs donc le masque
les élastiques cdm aux frontières ces
masques ne viennent donc pas de loin les
agents de la ville les ont déposés dans
des corbeilles dédié ils sont ensuite
collecté une fois par semaine est amené
à reitnau rec pendant trois mois une
expérimentation est mis en place entre
l'entreprise et la commune un circuit
court qui permet d'allier écologie et
économie locale
pour eux c'est une aide une aide au
développement de rentrer de leur
entreprise et pour nous c'est un vrai
conventionnement je dirais utile
pratique on aimerait que ça se développe
davantage même dans les écoles si
possible on va bien voir avec rec norrec
comment ils sont capables de récupérer
tous ces matériaux le procédé permet à
l'entreprise de recycler le masque en
entier élastique et pince nez en métal
compris on l'a testé l'été dernier on a
vu que ça fonctionnait et on s'est dit
que pour que ce soit sérieux il fallait
que la matière finale et de la valeur
est donc cette qualité et donc on a
déclenché les masses qui une opération
expérimentale pour finir de mettre au
point ce
ce procédé les plaques rennweg fabriqués
en partie avec les masques peuvent
devenir par exemple des composteurs ou
des nichoirs pour oiseaux